the Democrats did not pay for what I
think a lot of us thought they were
going to pay for I think a lot of us
that are Freedom loving that don't want
to be injected with [ __ ] and chop kids
genitals off and all that stuff we
thought that more people I suppose were
like us now it should be noted that the
Republicans won the popular vote in the
midterms by about 5 million votes
they're still you know they're still
trying to figure out the exact amount
because we're a week later and they're
still kind of votes but Republicans did
get more votes Republicans will get the
house uh Florida went solidly right as
you know New York picked up I think I
think they flipped four blue seats red
so like some good things did happen here
but but broadly speaking the people who
locked everybody down and crushed
economies and all that stuff they did
not pay the price uh Gretchen Whitmer
you guys know it I've told you about her
many times she is one of the worst the
idea that this woman was re-elected uh
Tudor Dixon did a fine fine job I was
really impressed by her and I hope that
she has a a bright political future in
front of her and if she doesn't want to
do politics she had a good career
beforehand then she'll be just fine but
Gretchen Whitmer was voted in again the
people they voted people in who were
locking them down and then not abiding
by their own lockdowns here's Whitmer
because now they launder the lies she
goes on CNN uh claiming that she won
because you know she's focused on the
right stuff keep the governor's office
but also control both Chambers in your
Michigan legislature first time that's
happened in almost 40 years what
takeaways do you have for National
Democrats about your win in Michigan
well I can tell you we stayed focused on
the fundamentals right whether it's
fixing the dam roads or making sure our
kids are getting back on track after an
incredible disruption in their learning
I mean it's just incredible it's just
incredible this woman kept kids out of
school for a year and a half almost into
two years in the debate as you know she
said she only did it for three months
she bold face lied I didn't see any
Washington Post Pinocchio lie check on
that thing the idea that people it's
it's unfathomable to me
it is it unfair yeah it's unfathomable
not in fathom it's unfathomable to me
that people said we want more of that
but that's what people in Michigan
decided to do uh she also said that the
Democrats ran on bodily autonomy which
is a little confusing to me because I'm
fairly certain they wanted to inject
people with vaccines that don't work
make people's lives better but also
protect our ability to make our own
decisions about our bodies these are
fundamental core issues if we're going
to design our lives and make our
decisions around our families that is
you know without question an economic
decision as well
that's interesting so the woman who was
forcing people out of jobs locking
people up at home now she was going out
and partying with her husband on their
boat during all the lockdowns and all
that stuff you guys know that the
hypocrisy knows no end
um she's suddenly interested in bodily
autonomy so when it was about abortion I
guess she's really into the idea that
you should be able to kill an
eight-month baby okay fine but when uh
it was about you making a decision hey
I'm 27 years old and I eat right and I'm
otherwise healthy and you know I'm a
little skeptical of things that just
appear out of nowhere and mRNA
technology and maybe I don't want to get
this vaccine and I take good care of
myself she was not for bodily autonomy
then right so the idea that they could
even say that with a straight face it is
just incredible as if they care about
freedom and then she links it to the
economy and it's like well lady you
destroyed the economy has she been to
Detroit lately you do not want to go to
Detroit people it's like downtown
Fallujah
Fallujah